Welcome to our third company of Scholars
lecture for this Academic Year uh I'm
delighted to uh introduce uh my friend
and neighbor Gary
Tomlinson uh whose uh work I'm eager to
hear about because we I'm very
interested in music but we don't speak
about his work socially in our
neighborhood so uh uh he Gary's the John
Hay Whitney professor of music and of
the humanities here at Yale and he came
from the University of
Pennsylvania uh he's a PhD uh graduate
of UC Burke from uh
1987 and the next year he got a
MacArthur Fellowship so you must have
written a smashing thesis Gary to be
receive that kind of9 for the for the
graduation oh really that's that was
incorrect on your Wikipedia
page first mistake ever
on so Gary is the author of five learned
texts on on music and also the co-author
of a popular music appreciation book uh
today we're going to hear about his
current work on the evolutionary
emergence of Music uh among Mankind and
his lecture topic today is 1 million
years of
Music
Gary thank you thank you very much for
all coming
out on this baly spring afternoon um I
said I said to my undergraduates on on
Monday at least we're done with the snow
and they said don't jinx it they were
they were right um uh the the title that
you see on the screen in front of you I
am I miked appropriately by the way is
everything okay all right the title you
see on the screen in front of you is the
title of a book that will be coming out
in the coming months um and I want to
say two things about this title um uh
number one there were not one million
years of Music um not of human musicing
to be sure um though Rick PR just told
me he's going to do 150 million years of
music that's a different musical story
than I'll be telling today um uh there
were not one million years of music but
the point of the title is to say that
unless we look back a long long way in
homin evolution we're not going to get
any full picture of how it is that music
and musicing capacities musicing as a
term I'll use a lot musicing capacities
came about and the second thing about to
say about this um this title is note the
assertion in the subtitle that that
somehow talking about 1 million years
that is the emergence of Music
incapacities could in fact tell us
something very general about the
emergence of human modernity all told
I'll have a little bit to say about that
later on in in the talk um it certainly
is a major theme toward the end of the
book but let's start uh with something
much much more recent let's start with
the end of the story that I want to tell
um here is a wonderful cute little
artifact uh that was on Earth not so
very long ago um this comes from the
suabian Ura that is that that region of
the the suabian Alps to the Southwest
portion of of Germany where near the uh
source of the danu river um uh in
several different caves over the last
several decades and in fact in fact in
some of the sites even farther back but
certainly over the last few decades in a
number of different caves an arresting
array of artifacts have been Unearthed
um this one is one of the cutest one of
the most wonderful it's about this big
um uh it is carved out of mammoth ivory
it is the figurine of of a woolly
mammoth it is one of a series of
figurines that come from fogal haired
cave in one of these sites that that I
just mentioned there is a famous horse
there are several other m there are
there is a feline figure there is a a
bird uh there are several different uh
uh there's a whole array of these from
from fogal cave um now the artifacts
that I'm going to show from this region
of near the the mouth near the source
rather of of the danu river these um
these artifacts take us back to what AR
archaeologists think are are the
earliest um uh artifacts or some of the
very earliest artifacts made by Homo
sapiens in uh in Europe um uh do we know
for sure that they were made by Homo
sapiens we don't know much of anything
for sure about these things but but it
is almost almost undoubted that they
must be the product of homo sapiens all
the behavior that we know of the one
other species that was very prominent of
hominins at this time in this region
that is to say homon nandal insus or the
neols suggests that they were not up to
this kind of handiwork though they were
up to some pretty significant and
sophisticated handiwork um so from this
from another cave holenstein schle um uh
from this same region comes the famous
Lion Man holenstein stotle um this is a
this is a statue again of mammoth ivory
it's about this big it was first
Unearthed in 1939 uh in uh it was not
put together it was not even seen to be
a puzzle that needed to be put together
until some uh some archaeologists looked
at it some 30 years later and pieced it
together into this striking figure of a
humanoid body and and a feline a feline
head I'll talk more about this a little
bit later from this same area of all of
these uh uh of all of these Caves at the
near the source of the the danu um uh
come the earliest musicing artifacts
that we have uh and I'm going to show
you a series of these now um this is uh
this is a a pipe from uh gon clly
another one of these uh sites it is uh
made from the the radius one of the Wing
Bones of of a very large Swan uh this is
a fragmentary pipe a fragment of a
larger piece um uh it you can see that
it has been repaired and pieced together
from a lot of fragments in which it was
found um uh note the kind the
construction that would have been
involved the the the bone would have
been Hollow to start with the ends of
the bone were saw sawed off uh and and
then using a rasp of some sort that
working transversely across the pipe um
uh the the uh the holes were fashioned
not by drilling into the pipe but by
scraping until uh until a hole to the
interior was opened thus giving it that
characteristic beveled effect that you
see on the finger holes here's from also
from G and clly from about the same
period is um is a pipe made uh in a in a
very very very different and more
complex
fashion this now is made of mammoth
ivory and you can see um you can see a
number of features of this in order to
make it a mammoth ivory they had to cut
longitudinally split open a piece of
ivory Hollow it out on the insides and
then glue it back together uh making
finger holes in this case probably with
an all drilled into the into the ivory
because the ivory wouldn't break the way
the swan radius might have you can see
the seam running off the side where up
the side where it was sealed again you
can see the uh some notches along the
side that seemed to have been made in
order to help make the seal uh more
airtight maybe the adhesive we don't
know what adhesive was used maybe some
adhesive was was sticking better when
they made those notches the the little
tag up at the top of course is not part
of the artifact that's an
archaeologist's tag again made from
mammoth ivory in this case now in 19 in
20 2008 rather um uh uh some more
artifacts started turning up in in the
the last of these these uh danub Valley
sites that I want to talk briefly about
and uh and these are uh special for
several reasons that I'll that I'll get
to in just a moment here's another um uh
apparently musical pipe this one
fragmentary still but four four holes uh
uh four holes well preserved and perhaps
another hole down at the bottom maybe
another hole up at the top uh made now
from the radius of a griffin vulture um
uh this pipe from Hells Unearthed in
2008 by Nicholas conard and his team he
is one of the lead researchers in this
whole area at this at this moment here's
another picture of it with a singularly
Sinister uh vulture holding out his arm
so we can see just what bone was used um
uh and I made sure that I had this right
because I thought Rick PR might be here
this is it's not the bone that is
highlighted here it is this bone the top
bone this is the radius this is the alna
um um the alna also used in some other
pipes for um for uh in some other
archaeological artifacts as well uh
these hollow bones were very useful for
these musical pipes um again showing the
clear effect of beveled finger holes it
also signals a mistake that
archaeologists often enough make one
might assume that oh my goodness think
of think they're they're thinking ahead
to making airtight seals by beveling the
finger holes just the way we might in a
in in a in a in a modern
recorder and yet as I've already
explained the beveling is a necessary
effect of the way in which the finger
holes were were were made into the
interior a handy um serendipitous uh
outcome perhaps for for making the
airtight seal but not NE necessarily
something that they had to think about
in
advance
um this pipe was found at hell's um uh
uh right alongside is so close in such
close proximity with the next artifact
I'm going to show you that for one of
the rare instances at this historical
depth um the archaeologists surmised
that that the same people might have
been involved in making both of these
artifacts this is the so-called Venus of
holel rather a resting Venus um figure
uh Venus figures are famous from the
upper p lithic period in Europe but all
of them uh except for this one are much
much younger and I'll talk about the age
of these of these artifacts uh just now
in fact um the the uh uh all of these
artifacts sit at the far end of the
reliability of Carbon 14 dating so it's
been very very hard to get uh very to
get accurate dates of these artifacts uh
the problems have to do with the short
half-life of carbon 14 and the Trace
Amounts that are there in the first
place um that are then trying to be
measured six or seven half lives back
uh it has to do also with uh the um with
the calibration and the changing amounts
of carbon dioxide in the atmosphere over
these periods the calibration curves for
Carbon 14 dating are very very difficult
and and and controversial things but the
calibration curve now for carbon 14 has
been pushed farther than it had been
until recently and takes archaeologists
with confidence back well beyond 30,000
years and in some cases almost to 50,000
years some would argue almost to 50,000
years these artifacts stand in Carbon 14
dating now somewhere between 40 and
44,000 years ago these are hugely
ancient artifacts in other words they
are they are very very very distant from
us they might be as little as 5,000
years after the final Exodus of a couple
of lineages of homo sapiens came out of
Africa to populate the rest of the world
in the first place that close to the
migration Out of Africa maybe only 5,000
years maybe more maybe 10 or 15 but as
little as 5,000 years they're hugely
ancient artifacts and to give you a
sense of the chronological span that
we're talking about here if we look at
the next oldest pipes that that um uh
archaeologists have come across there's
a whole series of pipes some 21 or 22
pipes that came from isit's cave in in
the Pyrenees in The Basque region of
Southern France um uh the these pipes
they were Unearthed early this one has a
dating 1914 there you can see another
dating 1939 there the two halves were
not were were excavated some decades
apart um uh this series of pipes uh they
date back 201 to 25,000 years probably
something on that order um they are they
are in other words some 20,000 years
younger than the pipe that we were just
looking at from holfels um they um there
is one pipe that is that is thought to
be was asserted to be by the
archaeologists of an older vintage um
and yet the strateg graphy of the of the
excavation and the similar that was was
not done very precisely back in the
1930s and the uh the similarity of
design between that pipe and all the
others suggests that it was not in fact
chronologically separated very far from
them so those are isit pipes the next
the next oldest uh musical artifacts we
have uh 20,000 years younger or so than
the pipe from holfels um or some famous
Paleolithic uh uh Paleolithic handiwork
this is the hall the famous Hall of the
Bulls from Lasco in the dordon of of of
France of central France uh you can see
the Oro that dominates the scene with
horses superimposed over it and there's
a reindeer down at the bottom and some
characteristic abstract marks painted
around it that are very very frequent in
these Paleolithic paintings and very
enigmatic um the Hall of the Bulls dates
back something like 17 or 17.5 or 18,000
years much much more recent once again
if we want to push back the history of
of Paleolithic cave painting on the
Monumental scale of Lasco we can push it
back to gr chave from the Eastern
Eastern portion of Southern France
discovered only in the 1990s here is the
famous panel of horses from GR some of
you may have seen verer herzog's movie
uh uh the Cave of Forgotten Dreams on a
very romantic but quite marvelous
pictographically uh cinematically um uh
exploration of chave it chave was
immediately closed it has never been
open to the public as soon as it was
discovered it was it was closed closed
for archaeological study um uh this this
panel of horses at first it was asserted
that it was 30 or 32,000 years old which
makes it arrestingly ancient as well uh
the that that dating has now been begun
to be revised down into the 20s once
again we're still uh 10,000 years at
least uh younger than uh than those than
those those artifacts from hells and if
we want to go back farther to artifacts
that have some sort of sense of usage
about them that is not utilitarian that
is to say not not not just tools for
scraping and cutting and so on and so
forth we can do that but in order to do
that we need to we need to head out of
Africa out of Europe and into Africa in
fact and here is is the the the poster
child so to speak for early so-called
symbolic Behavior among Homo sapiens in
Africa s that word symbolic is a deeply
pernicious one in archaeology these days
and and I try not to use it without
careful definition uh but it's usually
talked about as symbolic Behavior here
it is from blomo cave on the southern
coast of South Africa a piece of enzed
ochre it's about 4 Ines long about this
big um the incisions have been studied
to a fairly well uh they were made with
some sense of design involved in in
scraping them into this and there are
many other pieces that have been found
in blombo's cave now of similar
Antiquity to this that have other insize
designs on them this was not in other
words the halfhazard uh product of
cutting some meat on top of a piece of
ochre or something like that um the um
uh uh this this piece dates back to more
than 70,000 years 70 to 77,000 years 73
is the is the name that is usually that
is the number that is usually assigned
to it all right now all of this
archaeological evidence of of musicing
uh specifically those pipes and so on
that I've been showing you all of this
archaeological evidence is the end of
the story that I want to tell and the
question is how can we describe the
earlier
stages we need to come we need to make
some general statements first of all
about music and human or homine
Evolution uh and and the the the three
terms that I will that I will highlight
in these General statements are first of
all uh any such complex Behavior as as
human or human musicing needs to be
thought of and its emergence needs to be
thought of in incremental terms we need
to take the behavior apart part into its
into its uh into its component parts and
understand how and why those components
might have emerged rather than taking
musicing as a whole and trying to say
why did music emerge if you read
accounts of the origin of music of which
there are many these days in in in the
in the literature some of it popular
some of it some of it scholarly uh you
will see again and again the mistake
made of of of people trying to say well
how did musicing emerg it must have
emerged because people wanted to bond
socially so they started doing music or
people wanted to sing to their infants
so they started doing music um these of
course just beg a whole lot of questions
about how it is that capacities for
making music came to the species in the
first place why it is those capacities
uh that came no doubt for non-musical
purposes coales into musical practices
all of those questions are begged by the
notion of taking music as a whole as the
as the
object so we need to have an incremental
account we need to have a
co-evolutionary account um a
co-evolution I will talk about in some
detail in just in just a moment so I'll
come back to that and leave that aside
for the moment we need to we need to
have an account that involves culture
and by culture here I mean something
that can be defined very
straightforwardly and very simply I mean
the the the notion of learned behaviors
in one generation that are then passed
along through mimesis teaching and
various other uh various other behaviors
to successive Generations I don't mean
more than that by culture and with that
definition culture is a very very widely
dispersed uh phenomenon in the animal om
if you read Michael pollen's recent
article in in the New Yorker you might
know that some people would say culture
is widely dispersed in the plant kingdom
I don't go there in fact but um uh but
certainly it is widely dispersed in in
the animal kingdom so we need an account
that that in other words uh gives us an
incremental biocultural co-evolutionary
uh picture of how it is that that uh
that human musicing um took
shape so first we talk about some
increments then what are some of the
increments what are some of the basic
capacities that are involved in human in
human musicing well some of them are
very ancient very widespread far beyond
humans and and uh uh and U uh and very
general in their application auditory
scene analysis as it is sometimes called
um by people who study music cognition
and other sound cognition by the way
auditory scene analysis named in analogy
to visual scene analog analysis how is
it that our brain takes a a a jumble of
of of oral signals from from the the
world all kinds of noises and other
things and separates them off into into
into distinct streams of sound right how
does our brain make sense of the
auditory scene around us um how does it
distinct distinct oral streams is one
aspect of it distinct rhythmic pacings
would be another aspect of it distinct
acoustic amplitudes directionality from
which different sounds are coming all of
these are part of a very very general
generally dispersed uh auditory scene
analysis widely dispersed throughout
mammals to be sure and and and birds
also o to be sure uh and some probably
some other uh some other animals as well
uh in probably lowering levels of of of
complexity but not necessarily um so
auditory scene analysis is a very
ancient and very broad uh basis on which
musicing might happen hierarchic
processing or perception uh this is much
less basic and much less widely
dispersed I I think it is arguable uh
that that in certain forms hierarchic uh
cognition and processing um is very
narrowly limited uh to uh to a few
clades in in the uh in the animal
kingdom um by by hierarchic processing I
mean the capacity to take to take
stimuli from the external world and
process them in such a way that they
begin to Nest themselves uh a number of
stimuli uh nested in in in relation to
fewer stimuli nested in relation to
still fewer stimuli uh This Is
Fundamental to Modern human linguistic
capacities is fundamental to modern
musical capacities ities uh in human
musicing as well part of the fundamental
the one marker of the fundamental aspect
the fundamental uh uh importance of
hierarchic processing has to do with
perception of periodic rhythms in uh in
in human musicing today by which I mean
rhythms coming stimuli oral stimuli
coming at regular uh at regular uh time
intervals um the the capacity of of
hominins to and train themselves to um
to regular stimuli from the environment
is an astonishing capacity astonishingly
astonishingly complex in fact it is
sometimes known by music cognitivists as
beat-based processing referring to the
beats in metered music of course um uh
this uh this perception of periodic
rhythms is not as widespread Beyond uh
humans in the world today as we might
think some of you may have may have
looked on YouTube at Snowball the the
white coatu dancing to the Beasty Boys
well maybe um but aside from aside from
a few animals uh non-human animals in
close proximity uh uh that have been
raised in close proximity domesticated
in various ways and raised in proximity
with humans it's hard to find really
clear examples of the kind of beat-based
processing with its hierarchic ordering
of of of regular stimuli into larger
groups uh uh larger groups of of those
stimuli it's hard to find many instances
of this uh in the animal kingdom so the
perception of periodic rhythms and
entrainment and beat-based processing
all of these are related phenomena
tremendously basic to music and human
musicing the sensitivity to pitch we
might think well isn't that the same
thing as the sensitivity to sound but of
course it is not uh humans manage to
distinguish for one reason or another
and it doesn't take music training to do
this it simply is something that we grow
into in our normal socialization and
ontogeny we distinguish uh those sounds
that come to us from the world that have
a fundamental frequency and then
overtones above that frequency ordered
in simple integer ratios 2: 1 3 to 3:2 4
to 5 and so on WE distinguish those from
other sound stimuli that come to us in
the world those things we give the name
pitch to whatever name we want to give
to it it doesn't matter the other things
sound like noise it is the difference
between the
and that's got an incredibly chaotic
array of overtones above the the
fundamental frequency when I when I and
and if you beat on a bass drum it's the
same thing but the pitch that I just
sang has an ordered uh uh uh array of
overtones or partials above its
fundamental frequency this capacity of
our brain to do this is a hugely
mysterious capacity it might have to do
with neural networks that are in in
which the neurons are somehow firing in
those precisely in those ordered uh
simple integer ratios but if so we
haven't been able to test this and find
this and locate this very clearly yet um
uh the explanation for the the actual
kind of neural explanation for many of
the things I'm talking about today
remain quite opaque and mysterious but
sensitivity to pitch is fundamental uh
and from it by the way arise the kinds
of distinctions of tamber that that we
that we make use of in music all the
time also in language but in a very
different way in language sensitivity to
tamber or tone color has to do then not
only with the the the overtones above a
frequency but it has to do especially
there are several aspects to it it has
to do with the onset of of a sound the
decay of the sound all sorts of things
but one of the most important aspects
has to do with the the the different
weighting of overtones above a
fundamental frequency so that if a
trumpet and a violin play the same pitch
the reason we hear one is different from
another has to do with the differential
waiting of the partials above the
fundamental frequency uh that is played
by both instruments um distinctions of
tamber tamber by the way in language is
tremendously important vocal vowels in
in all human languages are distinguished
by by rather discret application of of
of different tambers within individual
languages the perception of discrete
pitch levels then is only slightly is is
a new is a different kind of wrinkle
that I'll talk about more later on top
of this sensitivity uh sensitivity to
pitch this perception of discrete pitch
levels or intervals um has to do with
the fact that once homon at some point
came to be able to discern pitch and
here it is different from disordered
noises in the world um they're setting
at some point a very general capacity to
relate pitches to one another in
hierarchic modes of one sort of one sort
or another so hierarchic cognition is
involved here again and this has to do
for instance with what in Western uh
musical parlot we call octave
equivalence a fund a pitch with a
fundamental frequency here and a pitch
with a fundamental frequency twice that
fundamental frequency sound incredibly
closely related to human listeners
there's some evidence that there are
some other species Mack monkeys certain
Birds but not other birds also hear this
octave equivalence and perceive it but
it doesn't extend hugely as far as
experimental evidence has has shown us
so far so opave equivalence once you've
got a sense of of this octave
equivalence the the the the spectrum of
pitch sounds that come can be broken up
into smaller intervals also related
typically by small integer ratios 3:2
4:5 6:5 and so on um these um uh uh
these smaller intervals in fact give us
the the scales that are used in in
musics in musical systems all over the
world are they in any sense fixed no
they are not uh the the arrays they they
it is it is pretty clear at this point
that musical systems tend to choose
pitches within the octave that gravitate
towards certain Central points but these
pitches are are marvelously malleable
the gravitation points are so to speak
attractors in in a in a in a very very
interesting complex system but they
don't they are not they are not uh they
are not determinants and they are not in
any in any way fixed nonetheless once
again we hear uh we see in this
phenomenon of of discret pitch um the
play of uh the play of uh of U simple
integer ratios somehow entering into our
our our uh perceptual structure one of
the basic lessons to take away from this
whole slide that I've spent so long on
is that there's no such thing as simple
music um people long ago um uh linguists
long ago uh realize that in natural
human languages none of them are simple
they are all they are all ordered in
extraordinarily complex ways and they
and they require a complexity of COG
cognition that is essentially unknown
outside of uh beyond the human Beyond
humans Homo sapiens in the world today
um
the the same is true of music there is
no such thing as simple music a a a
mother humming a lullabi to uh to a
nodding child on the one hand uh a uh a
group of football fans chanting a
chanting their teams chant at in a
football stadium um may be simpler in
many many ways than a malarian orchestra
playing or than a gamalon a 30-piece
gamalon band playing in in in Bali yes
it is simpler and yet all of those
phenomena have already crossed over a
bar of such huge cognitive complexity
that the differences between them are
insignificant compar compared to the
difference between musicing and
non-using ultimately
okay now I've just be brought up the the
the question of language and of course
we can't talk about the Advent of human
musicing without talking about the
Advent of language as well um the um the
an incrementalist view which I think we
have to take into to language just as
well as as we have to take it to to
human musicing an incrementalist view is
going to suggest finally that that that
these that increments uh were reach
reach back the increments of modern
language and the increments of modern
Human music reach back far before either
musicing or language existed these
increments were falling out in hominine
behaviors and capacities for a long long
time in some of the most General cases
they reach very far back but in the
cases the more specific cases that I'm
talking about here as I've said at the
beginning the last million years or so
will get us a long way in trying to
understand how they came about um but um
uh these parallel uh these parallel
components these components fell out in
in ways that are moving forward through
the evolution of hominin in still
distinct and separate ways and finally
perhaps overlapping in some ways uh uh
perhaps uh uh quite distinct from one
another in other ways but they are un
they are they are developing at a moment
when there is no such thing as language
and there is no such thing as musicing
right neither of these exist for a long
long time yet to come so here's a very
simple and very bad
use of PowerPoint chart that might might
show something like this in schematic
terms there you have a million years
back here you have a set of capacities
that are represented by the arrows there
you have on this left hand side you've
got capacities that are uh that that on
the far side are more and more specific
to human musicing today on the right
hand side capacities that are more and
more specific to language and speaking
uh today in the middle you got a broad
range of capacities that overlap and
that are used that are made use of in
both musicing and language but the point
is that the ages of these different
capacities are vastly different and
there is some moment of of coalesence a
long moment of coalesence mind you but a
moment of coalesence that probably
happens in my estimation after 100,000
years ago when modern musicing and
modern language fall out they both
coales out of these uh sets of uh of
components that had been developing for
a long long
time now if we're going to take this
incremental view it raises the question
immediately of the Proto music and the
Proto language that came before so what
can we surmise about the nature of this
Proto music and this Proto language say
500,000 years ago a group of homo
heidleberg anus at box Grove in in
Southern England trying to with a
complex social complex social uh
interactions uh they're Scavenging a
hippopotamus skeleton the skeleton has
been Unearthed the tools with which it
has been was scavenged have been
Unearthed and so on um they're uh
they're working hard they're working as
a group to fend off the hyenas that also
want to scavenge the the hippopotamus uh
carcass
um what kind of complex communicative
Network can we imagine for for this
group um uh we can surmise a whole lot
from first of all what archaeologists
tell us about the social organization of
these groups and the social
possibilities they they uh uh they
extrapolate this especially from Stone
tool making of virus and the techniques
involved we can surmise a whole lot from
primate communication and behavior in
the world today we can look to some
other sources as well for for our
speculations they are speculations of
course uh but first we have to assert
that it is a complex communicative
Network that was at stake here there is
no language there is no modern musicing
but there is a complex communication at
stake it probably involved both innate
and learned vocalizations vocal gestures
and also bodily
gestures these gestures probably had the
first uh the first burden of carrying an
effective charge from one of these
individuals to another co-present
individual so the emotional charge was
first and foremost and what was
expressed in all likelihood that
emotional charge aimed at manipulating
the other individuals around so that
they would do the things that the person
who was expressing these emotions wanted
done there probably were gestures and
even vocal gestures that pointed towards
towards things in the world towards
other individuals and so on dtic
gestures as linguists tend to call such
things
um and the signals are almost
undoubtedly not discreet in the in the
manner of modern language I'll come back
to that discreetness later they were
rather it was it was a question of
analog signaling analog signaling
signals that that especially in the
vocalizations because discreetness comes
easily to bodily uh uh to bodily signals
but it comes less easily to to vocalize
signals this um uh this analog signaling
uh would would have involved a graded
spectrum of signals so that so that h
means one thing ah means something else
ah means something else and yet the one
thing and something else and something
else are not clearly distinguished from
one another they simply are carrying
larger charges of affect larger
manipulative charges right um uh so
analog signals um the question then
would be what processes could transform
this kind of communication into modern
musicing and modern language and now we
turn from increments uh and
incrementalism to co-evolution and the
nature of coevolution and here's a very
very basic sketch of what I mean by
coevolution in the first place this is
this is fundamental uh in evolutionary
thinking today uh it certainly it it
reaches all the way back it's very
clearly signaled if with a slightly
different vocabulary already in darwins
On the Origin of Species um and here it
is what I mean is something very simple
a feedback Network between organism and
its environment and the the environment
by the way including all the other
organisms in it whether of the same
species or of different species you've
got an environment that is a selected
terrain that is exerting some kind of
selective pressures on an organism or a
group of organisms or a species and so
on you've got an organism or organisms
or species that are at the same time um
at the same time altering the
environment on which they live in the
course of their lifeways and what
happens is is that that the the and in
the term that is usually used the niche
of this organism is slightly altered by
its own life lifeways of the species the
organism whatever uh the niche is
constructed by the organism at the same
time as the organism is constructed
across natural selective time scales by
um by the impact of of selective
pressures a changing environment the
changing environment brought about in in
part by the organism simple feedback a
simple feedback model seems to me is
basic to the definition of of
co-evolution this feedback by the way
once again the envir includes all of the
network of organisms in in this
environment not just the inert inorganic
environment um this is in essence the
entangled bank with which Darwin
finished very famously his On the Origin
of
Species the once we start talking about
cultural animals however remember
animals that that learn behavior in a
lifetime and then teach it or pass it
along somehow to successive gen
Generations once we start talking about
cultural animals we get into biocultural
co-evolution which is a rather different
animal entirely and and here's uh here's
a slightly enhanced model of the
feedback Network in this case part of
the niche constructive feedback to the
to the uh to the environment has to do
with in fact the cultural behaviors of
the species that is involved right those
cultural behaviors uh can be collections
of behaviors they can be even even
rather discret collections of behaviors
I call these discreet collections of
behaviors archives cultural archives and
and homins have for a very very long
time been uh been putting together
cultural archives that they then pass
along to successive Generations these
archives have immense power to alter The
Selective terrain more power might one
might argue than many other kinds of
non-cultural behaviors that that animals
might be up to though not more in all
cases so let's look at at a simple
example of a cultural
archive here is an auli hand Ax from
about 700,000 years ago uh a biface um
uh rather symmetrical uh made from from
Flint napping or stone napping of one
sort or another you chip down a a larger
core until you until you get to get to
the shape um a shape something like this
this uh uh this aulian uh uh uh
technology came in first about 1.7
million years ago it's immensely ancient
and once it settled in it became a
cultural Archive of huge permanency and
stability um it lasted for another
million years before in fact there were
really significant um uh changes in the
technological toolkit of the homin that
are our ancestors and other homin
species as well um the the the point
about this as a cultural archive is that
there was a collection of gestures that
was needed in order to be to to in order
to somewhat reliably come out with
something that had some semblance of
symmetry um as the biface that was uh
that that was that was sought uh that
could be used as some sort of tool um
this operational sequence as
archaeologists tend to call it this
operational sequence is the cultural
archive as I'm envisioning it right it
is it is an archive of behaviors a
collection of behaviors that comes to
have some sort of coherency to it that
is then passed along from generation to
Generation all
right things get then a little bit more
complicated because there's one more to
this co-evolutionary model as I see it
um as cultures begin to sediment
themselves as archives in homin in the
homon and clay in particular and I think
it's arguable that there's no other
there's no other group of animals in
which um this phenomenon happened to
anywhere near the same extent but
already early on by say 500,000 years
ago those homo homo heidleberg anes
cutting up the hippopotamus carcass
already early on these cultural archives
are coming to be sedimented as I would
put it getting they getting deeper and
deeper in their complexity the things
that are passed along the body of
archives that is now passed along from
generation to generation among hominins
is getting more and more complex and uh
and and more and more sophisticated um
as this happens there is there is the
possibility of something new I call this
something new a cultural epicycle so
here is now epicyclic biocultural
co-evolution you've got the same the
same kind of feedback model is is is at
stake here uh you've got cultural
archives that are that are that are that
are taking a part in the niche that are
taking a major part in the niche
construction but at the same time every
once in a while you have these a falling
out of a rather systematic array of of
uh of uh of cultural behaviors a
systematic array that for various
reasons takes on its own its own
systematization its own formalization
its own ways of moving somehow that
comes almost to have a life of its own
not as a living thing of course but as a
a collection of behaviors and once it
does this it extracts itself ever so
slightly from the feedback cycle it
becomes a what I'm calling again an
epicycle it it it becomes a set of
behaviors that that in its own formality
in its own formalization has now has now
come to to carry its own complexity and
generate its own complexity and once it
does that it can then feed forward into
the the the main feedback cycle uh the
coevolutionary feedback cycle a feed
forward element the only difference
between a feed forward element and a
feedback element is the IND dependence
of the feed forward element from the
feedback mechanism and it seems to me
that what is happening in crucially over
the last say 500,000 years ago that
differentiates hominin Evolution from
every other kind of evolution that had
happened in the world before is the
proliferation of these these formalized
epicycles of cultural behavior that then
take on a role as a feed forward uh
element in in the the larger uh Flux Of
of feedback so let me let me give you
two examples one Musical one not of of
uh of of these epicycles by the way I
don't draw the line in any very firm way
as to what we want to call an epicycle
and what we might want to call a
slightly looser array of cultural
behaviors could we call the aulian Handa
uh uh set of behaviors in epicycle sure
uh why not it certainly came to have
something of of of an independent life
of its own as it was taught again and
again and again through tens of
thousands of generations of hominins not
in one species but in many different
species think of that a technology that
extends across many different species
lasts for over a million years in a very
stable form um and yet is a cultural
attainment that is taught again and
again and
again a cultural attainment of course
based on fundamental uh innate
capacities of various sorts but
nonetheless a cultural
attainment so here are a couple other
examples of of more clearer examples it
seems to me of what of what I mean by
this epicycle here is the here is the
bead making epicycle for instance now
bead making by which archaeologists mean
any little object that a hole is drilled
in so that it might be hung on hair it
might be hung on clothing it might be
hung on a string to make a make a
necklace or a bracelet or something bead
making is hugely ancient it the earliest
instances we know are about 100,000
years old it is very widely dispersed in
fact so widely dispersed that we cannot
believe that that in fact this was a
matter of one group of homin teaching
another group of hominins how to make
beads in some cases that no doubt
happened but in many other cases it
seems to have popped up independently uh
from in in various groups um so how did
it happen well here's one model of how
this epicycle might have taken shape uh
you in a situation of of growing social
complexity a situation in which that
that we can see from the Technologies
and the burgeoning Technologies of these
groups say aund thousand years ago we're
not talking about Homo sapiens Homo
sapiens the Advent of homo sapiens is
now placed something like 200,000 years
ago um uh but uh the uh the um in in a
situation of growing social complexity
there part of that social complexity
might well have been uh the the
realization of of different kinds of
alliances within the group they might
have had to do with kinship they might
have had to do with aspects of invisible
statuses that were that were involved
that certain that acred to certain
members of the group ranks and so on the
chief of the group and so on um uh this
is an expression clearly of hierarchic
cognition once this kind of sociality
sets in uh Hier hierarchic cognition is
long since since present in hominins
neander tool making shows very very
clear instances of of hierarchic
organization um uh uh but under the
influence of this new appearance so to
speak of invisible aspects of culture
rank within a group for instance um
under the appearance of this in the in
the the presence of all kinds of skilled
material workmanship what could be more
natural than that small objects would be
taken to decorate bodies with and to
Mark so to speak the otherwise invisible
status of individuals um what what could
be more natural than that there might be
a proliferation in many different homin
groups including
neols perhaps though bead making a un
Neanderthal still remain somewhat
controversial um but certainly many
different uh Homo sapiens groups what
could be more natural than than that
there would be not just a proliferation
of this epicycle this particular bead
making epicycle but in fact um uh a
repeating of the springing up of the
epicycle in very different far-flung
places and by the way with very
far-flung materials it can be sea shells
as as as you see here it can be um uh it
can be uh minerals in some cases it can
certainly be bones and teeth they're
very frequently used it can be ostrich
shells which are very frequently used in
in northern and western and Eastern
Africa and so
on all right a simple example of of uh
of uh a cultural epicycle here's a more
complex example the case of discrete
pitch and then I will then I will
conclude I'm loading you up with all
kinds of things here and I hope there
will be uh there will be some some
questions afterwards um a more complex
epicycle in this situation of increasing
social
complexity we have a situation
necessarily of increasing communicative
communicative complexity um the communic
the vocal gestures that I talked about
in protol language and Proto music are
now are now proliferating they are
getting more and more frequent they are
getting more and more elaborate perhaps
um the the we could imagine easily
enough a sharpening distinction of
intonational elements that would be used
in making some of these signals but if
you take an analog graded spectrum and
you start making sharper and sharper
distinctions you come up with a problem
because the closer things are on that
analog Spectrum the less you can
different less easily you can
differentiate them the signals are not
working any longer there would be a
pressure at some point for a
discretizing a making discreete of In
fact the graded analog Spectrum um I
think exactly what happened in in the
case of of animals that were already
perceiving pitch and perceiving it
differently from the noises of the world
world the percussive noises of the sort
that I the uh that I just exemplified um
I think what happened was uh was
precisely in these animals that were
already hearing pitch um uh pitch came
to be a more and more discreet element
along these analog signals but something
interesting at this point happened a
divide between the overall Contours
intonational Contours of utterances that
we still use to express ourselves today
in language and in music overall melodic
Contours overall Contour to speech
phrases and so on the pro as linguists
call it of of speech um uh that never
went away that ancient that very very
ancient part of of protol language and
Proto musicing that was one of the older
components it never went away but what
happened was that pitches individual
pitches came to be abstracted from that
a that effective signaling and once they
came to be abstracted the systematizing
of pitch rays that I talked about before
octaves and smaller intervals within the
octaves began to fall out according to
the capacity
that depended on small integer ratios
for hearing pitch in the first place you
get a cultural epicycle that is pushing
towards an abstraction of discret pitch
from the general melodic Contours that
are still a very very powerful element
of communication both protom musical
communication and protol linguistic
communication what happens then we can
easily imagine uh in in in uh there
would be new socially effective uses
then for these pitches and I'll talk
about some of those uses in just a
moment but I want to emphasize once more
this new this new distinction that has
come about between General melodic
Contours and discrete pictures this is a
distinction that is very operative in
human musicing today it is a distinction
that is operative in a rather different
way in human language especially tonal
languages which have intonational
structures large International
structures across phrases but also have
some discret tones that are used of
course to convey uh meaning as
well the epicycle then of discret pitch
all right so the the coalescing then of
human modernity say 120 to 60,000 years
ago it seems to me that it involves
fundamentally this abstraction of
thought and cognition and this
abstraction of thought and cognition is
falling out at the same time in the
conversion so to speak of Proto protol
language into modern language of Proto
musicing into modern musicing of social
practices that are now taking on
increased complexity with invisible
Realms attached to them ranks and
statuses and other sorts of kinds of
organization new complexities recognized
in kinship organization one the argument
has recently been made that that
somewhere with somewhere uh uh back from
40 to 80,000 years ago would have been a
time when when kinship systems of the
sort that humans universally recognize
today in their societies of a huge array
of sorts that they universally recognize
would have come into Focus for the first
time um whatever we take out we take out
of these specific arguments what Isen
Happening Here in the most General sense
is what Anthropologist Morris block
calls the appearance of the
transcendental social block talks about
the transactional social co-present
individuals working out transactions so
as to so as to get what they want in in
in the social organization of which
they're a part these are hugely
dispersed in non-human animals in the
world today and very very complicated in
non-human animals in the world today it
is arguable that at least uh Beyond
certain very rudimentary levels the
invisible Realms of social organization
are unique to humans in the world today
um and that is the what what block
refers to as the transcendental
social so the burgeoning of
transcendental sociality then involves
for instance language language
pragmatics that is to say a a discourse
that was protol linguistic and is
turning into modern language that is
nonetheless in which there are certain
kinds of of orderings of of uh of of
exchanges and so on and so forth taking
on the much broader and much uh uh much
more predictable ordering of modern
human linguistic discourse a movement
from what uh from language pragmatics
what linguist called pragmatics to what
Michael
Silverstein another linguistic
Anthropologist has called metapragmatics
meta pragmatics would have appeared
musical capacities musical capacities
now falling out in terms of organized
performative circumstances in which
these capacities would be called upon
and once we get to organize performative
circum circumstances to performances in
other words we talking about something
that comes very very close to the notion
of ritual in its modern and absolutely
ubiquitous human guise we're talking
about in all of this about offline
sociality not in other words I can react
and
communicate up with my co-present
individuals about the saber-tooth cat
that is threatening us but we can sit
around a campfire thinking about how
lucky we were to have escaped this
sabertooth cat that threatened us
earlier today offline sociality offline
um communication
with all of this this this appearance of
the transcendental social come imaginary
Realms come minimal counter intuitions
as this little statue is called it is
counterintuitive because it puts a
humanoid body with a with a a feline uh
feline head and yet it's minimally
counterintuitive because both the feline
and the human are very very are very
very um uh U are very very familiar what
we see across this period in other words
from say 75,000 years ago to 40,000
years ago is it seems to me the move
from that as as some sort of protos
symbolic behavior in the world to this
as as a full-fledged sense of a ritual
transcendency about human existence that
can be expressed in language in music
and in ritual behavior of all sorts and
in sociality in general so so what was
going on in Hells 40,000 years ago well
I think it's probably something very
similar to what was going on at chave
maybe 30 thousand years ago that's the
the the famous panel of the of the the
felines or
cats um or something very similar to
what was going on another 10,000 or so
years uh closer to us at leco or
Altamira here's the one of the famous
bison of Altamira same age more or less
as the paintings at Lasco that I showed
you earlier or now we now we see that
these these these expressive Realms of
humanity have taken on Monumental
proportions right in the paintings of of
Altamira or Lasco and those monumental
proportions are it seems to me stand in
a direct line to this next uh place
where something similar was going on
gbec Lee uh about 12,000 years ago in
Southeastern turkey that's been it's
been excavated only over the last 20
years it is an astonishingly early
huge ritual Center we don't know what it
is and yet it took a technology that we
wouldn't have imagined any hunter group
hunter gatherer group at the end of the
Paleolithic and beginning of the
Neolithic had the capacity to do um it
it uh it built these huge Stone Stell
with or pillars with with scorpions and
birds carved all over them uh there are
many of these these uh these complexes
uh there seems to have been nothing but
a hun gather of society around as far as
archaeologists can tell this gocke is a
complete mystery unless you see it in
the line that I have been tracing back
straight back through from the early
Neolithic all the way back through the
middle the the upper Paleolithic and all
the way back indeed to the African uh
middle Paleolithic or Middle Stone Age
as it is called and if we take that
straight line that continuous
development we see that that what's
going on at chave and Lasco and Altamira
and gocke is in fact not so different
from what's going on in jahu
China these were for some time claimed
to be the earliest musical instruments
they are something like 8,500 years old
they are carved with a with with a
technology they are made constructed
with a technology that is in fact now
almost 40,000 years old among humans by
the time these things are made almost
40,000 years old at 8,500 years ago um
uh they are made by making holes in
Hollow bird bone flutes in this case in
bird bird bones rather in this case the
uh the bones of red crowned cranes um so
in all of this continuity that I'm
pushing here um what we get is an
alternative to the old revolutionary
views about how human modernity came
about the Sapient Revolution 200,000
years ago then it was all different well
the more we learned about neander tals
the more we learned that they were
extremely complex creatures and and with
doing extremely complicated things um uh
those things are are are badly preserved
and hard for us to discern and there are
a whole lot of fights and arguments
about them among among archaeologists
but there's no question they're they're
are very complex the more we learn about
the ancestors of homo sapiens in Africa
the more we see them up to very great
complexities as well uh so the Sapient
Revolution begins to fade a little bit
the upper Paleolithic revolution around
40,000 years ago in Europe certainly
faded a long time ago there are those
who want to transpose it into Africa at
say 60,000 years ago uh but I think even
there there's a more gradualist kind of
kind of uh coalesence of forces that is
involved rather than some revolutionary
change the Neolithic Revolution well the
continuities between the the Monumental
structures um uh of the pyramids and
then another 8,000 years back the gcle
teepe and another only 6,000 years back
or 5,500 years back Lasco and Altamira
those continuities suggest that the
Neolithic Revolution has been overly uh
overly marked off it has to do with
Agriculture and sedentism and so on but
we learn more and more that the
domestication of crops and animals was a
gradual incremental development too it
didn't just start at the at the uh at
the beginning of the Neolithic we learn
more and more that sedentism existed
that is to say sedentary settlements
existed long before the beginning of the
Neolithic there are there are uh very
stable and quite permanent um uh
villages on the Ukraine uh on the
Ukraine steps made out of Mammoth tusks
and mammoth jaw bones at 18,000 years
ago now these people were hunter
gatherers they were hunting mammoths
clearly from the building materials they
used um uh but they were still building
stable structures and long lasting
structures and structures that were
absolutely
immovable so all of these boundaries
begin to all of these clear boundaries
that people want to to paint begin to
begin to fade the axial age at the first
in the first Millennium before Christ is
another of them that I that I think is a
highly dubious set of judgments about
about Novelties supposed novelties at
the time revolutionary Novelties at the
time um instead we get the gradual
appearance of modernity gradual
appearance and not just AC not just for
Homo sapiens but across several species
we get the coalesence of these these
features of modernity perh probably
finally in a small population of humans
around 60 or 70,000 years ago in East
Africa a population of humans that then
uh that then populated not only the
non-african world but as genetic studies
are more and more clearly showing moved
back into Africa and populated the
African World they me meeting there with
Homo sapiens groups some of which had
been separated from them for tens of
thousands of years and meeting up with
them again and Inter breeding with them
and and it seems to me that if there is
a coalesence if there is some one moment
at which this coalesence happens it
needs to be a tremendously Ancient One
it needs to be a long moment and it
probably is is located in this small
population but once the population
begins to spread in different places it
meets up with populations that are
already burgeoning with their own episy
and these epicycles merge with one
another in various ways these cultural
forces merge with one one another we get
a whole very very complicated history
that is being traced out now of climate
change of population migrations of the
homogenizations of populations and
genetic homogenation as well
homogenizations as well and we get um
this repetition and proliferation of
epicycles and from all of this it seems
to me we begin to construct something
when we look back that is an immense
continuity um uh traceable
in gradualist terms across the longest
periods much longer periods than we have
tended to imagine and bringing about
through this epicyclic kind of
co-evolution uh the the shared modernity
of all humans in the world today thank
you very much for listening to all my
words thank
you well thank you very much and uh has
already invited questions so let's hear
from the audience
Steve can you necessary
andent
cultural how do you put stuff into the
EP basket how do you keep it out well in
the first place I'm sorry excuse me was
that question not heard how do you
define an epicycle is there is there
some necessary sufficient set of
conditions that would allow one to
Define an epicycle and I already said
that there's not in my view that is we
might see we might see something like uh
like the isulan hand ax as a cultural
epicycle though if so it seems to be the
loosest of of S sorts an epicycle of the
loosest of sorts I will say this in the
most powerful of these epicyclic um uh
formations um there is there is a kind
of a kind of to use a word that is used
altogether too much these days but which
uh some of us are using in a seminar
right now to try and figure out there is
a kind of emergent complexity that comes
about that is a very very special sort
of thing it has to do with whatever the
elements are that that uh uh behavioral
elements acoustical elements in the case
of music and language and so on other
kinds of elements material interactions
with the world in a particular
circumstance but out of that conjures of
elements sometimes um something very re
formalized can can fall uh Terence
Deacon has a long argu argument about
about symbolic Behavior he defines
symbolism uh and the Advent of human
language much more carefully than most
archaeologists who want to talk about it
his book The symbolic species from 1992
was a very very important one it seems
to me um what he sees for instance in in
as a crucial moment of the coalesence of
language would be for me another
epicycle uh that is he sees a moment at
which signs of certain sorts are coming
to be indexical signs as Charles Sanders
Pur would call them pointing signs signs
that indicate things dtic signs as I was
saying before those signs are coming to
proliferate so much in human
communication that at a certain moment
the even even the the the necessity to
remember the signs is such that there is
a phase transition of sorts into a set
of signs that are self-referential and
come to have their meaning because of
the nature of the set itself that
defines for purse it defines in some
crucial ways what he means by a symbol
uh many for many curan linguists and
many other linguists it defines what how
language Works in a fundamental way for
Deacon he argues that that that that
would be a very very important moment he
I think he overplays how important it
was in h Evolution he sees language he's
a linguo Centrist he sees language as is
absolutely Central to everything um
nonetheless I think he's on the right
track and I think that I I think that
that that that is a great example of a
very careful of a very clearly
formalized epicycle necessary and
sufficient conditions no I don't have
them but something similar I think is
happening in discrete pitch whereby the
the acoustical uh small integer
relations the winnowing down of graded
uh of graded analog signaling systems
into into discret elements falls into a
kind of processing that then makes a
part of our EXP vocabulary the the the
production of discret pitch so I can't
formalize this epicycle but I know it
when I see it no no I don't I don't mean
to say that no no no I don't I don't I
don't mean that I think I think I think
in fact the attempt actually to
formalize it and make the boundaries
that you're asking for is something I
don't want to do I want to see a graded
move towards more and more complex
burgeoning of these cultural systems all
right something like that please so you
mentioned the about saing start 200,000
years ago and then at the last five you
had 60,000 years so sense is what the
difference is like on the discreet pitch
did the 200,000 year Street pitch or did
it take till 60 I'm trying to get some
sense the noice of
what are I think this is this is hugely
uh it is the center of of homo of homo
Sapient of Sapient archaeology right now
trying to figure out what happened be
between say it's something I don't know
175 to 200,000 years ago is what the
genetic evidence points to as the Advent
of homo sapiens well how reliable that
is in the first place is one question
and I'm not equipped to to make a
judgment on that but something on the
order of that let's say let's just take
it for for uh to try and answer your
question the distance between that and
the appearance of distinctly modern
human behaviors in terms of Technologies
and bead making and other sorts of
things the stuff at blombos Cave U by
the way the difference
between the chronological distance
between that that genetic coalescing of
of of something and and the coalescing
and the dispersion then of these these
remarkably different behaviors is huge
and nobody has a good explanation of it
I think that what uh uh my explanation
would have again to do with with the
proliferation the the gradual at first
accretion of more and more complex
cultural formations epicyclic cultural
formations and at a certain point a
Tipping Point being reached whereby
these epicycles are proliferating hugely
rapidly because of the very complex of
communication of sociality and and uh
and and of the brains of these of these
individuals themselves so I think
there's a big difference um uh there's a
big difference in Behavior between uh
Homo sapiens at 70,000 years ago and
Homo sapiens at 170,000 years ago but I
don't think that we have to look for a
huge difference genetically in order to
explain that difference that huge
difference in Behavior doesn't have to
be a huge difference genetically we
don't need to look for Magic Bullets the
language mutation Fox P2 genes and so on
and so forth we can explain through a
different set of means that are a part
of this complex web of biocultural
co-evolution all right yes please could
we go back to the slide of the human
body and the cat's head yes indeed we
could yeah um let's see if I know how to
get back we
could there it is yeah what's on the
left somebody's making triangles that's
not where scratch oh no indeed indeed
it's not you um sorry on the lower left
ler left
oh oh sorry sorry yeah no this is
extraordinary this is not random I
didn't say this was random no I just
wanted to remark doing
mathematics they're making CH they're
they're they're doing something
extraordinary with geometrical
geometrical arrangements and by the way
pale Paleolithic caves are and on some
very very old rock shelters in Africa
and so on The Dating of which is
immensely difficult these things are
filled with geometric figures of various
sorts one interesting place where you if
you want to to find a CL kind of
cockamamy but very interesting
speculation about such geometrical
figures read a book called The Mind in
the cave by David Lewis Williams Lewis
Williams is the last name the mind in
the cave it's a good read and and he
makes he makes some really good attempts
at trying to deal with these geometrical
figures yeah yeah other questions please
yeah I had a question about um the what
you were just saying about not looking
for a single formal formalizable um
vocabulary for discussing Cycles um and
I guess my question more about kind of
your discipline your intervention within
the discipline that you're working in
and seems to me that you're wanting to
argue against the kind of formalism of
uh cognitive processes or cultural
processes um and uh and I guess I'm just
wondering is there a way to
experimentally prove that there's that
there's not a formal sufficient
necessary condition for uh epis
cyclicity because can't someone always
come along can TR always come along say
well actually I do have the the kind of
formal um essence of this phenomena um
and in in the proc you're I guess the
real question I'm asking is uh yeah can
you beat that on its own on its own
terms or do you have to make of moral
argument so okay uh can I beat chiana's
own terms that's the the question no no
of course no the the question has to do
first of all there was a there was an
assertion in the question that it seems
to me that you're working against
formalization I'm not in fact I'm
working decomposing it backwards
absolutely of earlier things so
therefore you're coning the possibility
of formalizing cognitive processes um
that are more fundamental or earlier
yeah but isn't the real kind of I don't
know I want to call it a kind of ethical
thrust of your argument to argue that
the our inclination to look for formal
formal features um as the as the kind of
essence of music is something that needs
to be worked
again okay the p in pushing back I think
I'm understanding the question but I'm
not yet sure uh in pushing backwards the
question of formal formalization of
culture am I am I uh uh am I denying a
Chomp skin position that would say well
I'm going to give you the formal
structure say in the brain that from
which it all comes uh indeed I am um uh
I don't and there are two reasons that
you you asked me also about about
experimental possibilities um uh there
there are plenty of experiments being
done these days in music cognition uh
that point in all kinds of interesting
directions none of them point in my
reading of them point away from the kind
of development that I'm talking about
that I've talked about today um but I
would say in regard to to chomskian and
post chomskian approaches let's just
take post chomskian approaches to
language right those approaches have
reached largely a dead end in my view um
there there are some of them that are
much more Supple and subtle than others
in terms of the evolution of language
but there are others that simply throw
up their hands and Chomsky famously
threw up his hands and said we can't
explain through natural selective means
how language came about well Stephen
Pinker and Paul Bloom from from Yale
then in 1991 or 1992 put out a wonderful
article that laid out the ways in which
we could think of natural selection as
bringing about the complexities of
cognition and and production and so on
that are necessary for language to
happen that was a watershed argument
against chomskian mysticism ultimately
is which is what it the evolution of
language had come to seem in some ways
it was an argument against that but it
wasn't a sufficient argument in my view
um I think uh I think that that uh that
the bloom and Pinker argument and
especially then the Pinker argument in
the language instinct or how the mind
works those later books uh the bloom and
Pinker argument is one that um that does
not it is lingo Centric in the first
place it does not take account of huge
complexities of behavior and technology
and everything else that happened among
homans long before language could have
existed it does not then take account of
the generative complexity of sociality
and culture itself what's happening
between bodies as opposed to just in the
brain
uh and those things in the model that
I've laid out here are tremendously
important as forces in the
co-evolutionary cycles that I've been
talking about so um uh is there an
experiment do I want to prove this I
don't want to prove it I want to argue
it as capably as I can um I don't think
we're anywhere near proof about any of
these huge mysteries about how we came
to be the the creatures we are in the
world today um uh but I think one can
argue more effectively with this model
that reaches out to the play space
between bodies and works hard at those
cultural Dynamics we can explain better
with that than with a model that is that
is centered in the brain ultimately uh
now that's not to say by the way I I
don't mean to say for a minute that the
model that that what's going on in the
brain is not crucially important it is U
but if you don't have a brain that is
that is that is forming itself through
natural selective time periods in the
midst of this complex sociality I don't
see how you're going to get anywhere
near what we are today so that's the
that's the way I something like the way
I would answer the question that I think
you asked
Martin yes your your presentation
emphasizes continuity in the long
generation of these attributes and the
development of is there I'm just asking
is there room in this for a concept like
D's concept of punctuated equili where
things suddenly happen and stay stable
for a while advance in that way rather
than continuous yeah I want to say too
so the question the question is is there
room in my in my in my evolutionary View
for punctuated equilibrium for the
popping up for for periods of stasis
that are Then followed by a huge leap in
in in evolutionary change absolutely
there is room in it and not only that it
models in cultural terms how such a
thing would happen these epicycles are
all about punctuated equilibrium they're
all about things forming that suddenly
kick off new cultural and biocultural
possibilities so number one that it
seems to me is the case the only other
thing I'd say in answer to the question
is that it's always talked about as G's
punctuated equilibrium read on the
origin of species Darwin lays it out
right there he saw that punctuated
equilibrium was possible and he lays it
right out I don't know why G laid claim
to it he gave it a name so everybody
gives it to him but uh but it dates all
the way back to On the Origin of Species
uh by the way uh uh just a just a a
little you know don't read my book leave
my book aside but when it comes out read
On the Origin of Species if you haven't
it is one of the most miraculous books
and thought experiments that has ever
that has ever been produced and he sees
so much that is still basic he sees
co-evolutionary complexity he sees the
complexity of behaviors and how they
would develop in cultures the case the
case in point being the The Beehive and
how it might have come about he sees
punctuated equilibrium he sees a huge
amount all the while having not the
slightest idea how inherited variation
could have come about it was all a black
box to him and yet everything around the
black box was so clear so miraculously
clear what a what a book what a read yes
Martin I just a twofold uh Tory question
I the first one concerns your you could
say a little more about your definition
of musicing and how prati that category
is for you and what sort of work it does
and the second one is I mean in your
presentation today I mean you gave very
good sense of you know the position of
your argument that be very large to Bas
evolutionary theory but then like how
are you bringing all this to bear on an
intervention in musicology and what are
the stakes of that debate in terms of
your book this just an invitation to to
paint the broader cameras on your um so
the question is the first part of the
question is about um oh remind me sorry
mus so musicing what do I mean what do I
mean by musicing well thank you very
much Martin for that yeah um uh uh
anybody want to step up from the music
department of the back there and and
leap into this um so that's the first
question the second question they can
also step up in the back and leap into
the question of musicology where in
musicology might might this discourse uh
subsist um well this discourse first of
all um is uh is is a step aside from the
kind of musicology that I have spent
most of my career doing uh it's a step
to a different terrain but I don't think
I don't think it is a step uh that that
simply breaks its ties to musicology um
I think that what what the humanities
have done over the last 50 or 60 years
is continually and very productively
theorize and come to understand human
difference all the while they call
themselves the humanities and they
recognize that there was some
foundational sameness there that they
were not talking about it is time for
the Humanities to take take hold of the
coners ation about foundational sameness
that that make us all human um in ways
that are more than the platitudes about
what it means to be human that's what
you know that's what I don't know
listening to Beethoven is an affirmation
of what it means to be human well I
think that actually I feel that very
strongly and yet it doesn't tell me much
specifically about what it means to be
human um so the the humanities have been
the humanities of difference
tremendously productively they now need
to be both the humanities of difference
and the humanities of human sameness um
and and I think I think every humanistic
discipline needs to be thinking about
this if we don't think about it there
are cognitive scientists and a whole
bunch of other people out there many of
whom are my good friends who want to
think about it and they simply don't
have the training in the in in in the
humanities necessarily to understand as
well as they should what it is they're
trying what it is they're aiming at this
is the case of pinker's treatment of
music and how the mind works it's a
shameful treatment of Music he read Fred
lall and and and Ray Jack andof on
hierarchic structures in music and he
said oh I've got it all now and that was
it right um and so he dismisses it as
piggybacking on language and having no
independent status of it of its own
which I object to just because I'm a
musician and a musicologist but I object
also because it seems to me that this is
not the phenomenon that I know as music
right um so then you asked about the
definition of musicing
well I mean I've given you a pretty good
idea here as as best I can probably I'm
not sure that I'm not sure that I can
sum it up in a in a phrase or two it is
capacious it is necessarily capacious it
is a sense of something that is uh that
probably has to do with indexical signs
rather than symbols it has to do with a
kind of extraordinarily complexly
ordered set of indexical signs and
percepts that are produced that are not
carrying meaning the way language does
even though it then gets surrounded in
human behavior by language and comes to
carry all kinds of meanings um so
musicing musicing is is a very very
complex it's I think it's a unique human
feature I to to name something else that
that puts together in such a complex
fashion constructions out of
non-referential signals and signs is
almost impossible to do in human in
human behavior it seems to me and is
there anywhere in your account AES where
we go from non to mus say again I didn't
hear is there anywhere in your account a
Tres where we go from non musing to
musicing or is that capacious as your
entire presentation here the the
question was is there is there a
threshold from non-m musicing to
musicing um is there a chronological I
would say threshold from non- musicing
to musicing I think there is a CO a
momentous coalesence but I think it's
got to be over a very long span
now the other thing I will say in answer
to that is that the incremental the
incrementalism of the account suggests
that when this that that there can be no
moment in which a group of behaviors is
coherently together and then shifts from
non-music to music what you have to have
is components that coales at a certain
point and I think coales together with
language and coales together with
metaphysical perceptions the imaginary
realm all of these I think are
coalescing in human behavior and human
Capac ities at about the same time um
out of these mechanisms these epicyclic
mechanisms that's the argument um and
it's laid out in a greater detail in in
the book as to how that how that might
work but in that there is a capacious
view of musicing but there's no moment
at which non-m musicing becomes musicing
not at least unless a moment is thought
of in a very very broad terms mid's no
crer by which I could say this is mus or
mus even if I didn't want to give an
account of like a moment but there still
a Criterion that for what would be so
simple that it would no longer count
that's part of Music uh you know if what
I've already I've already in a sense um
said probably what I have to say and
answer that that the the question was
are there Criterion a criteria by which
we might say this is music but this is
not music um yes I think there are I
think they have to do with things like a
very precise kind of
entrainment of individuals listening to
other individuals working with other
individuals that is not found in the
same fashion in language even though
entrainment of of more General sorts is
hugely important in language a very
precise kind of entrainment on the one
hand a very precise kind of uh uh
deployment of this capacity to process
and perceive discrete pitch on the other
hand and you start putting these things
together into complex structures and
that's the moment at which it seems to
me to happen I don't know whether that's
the threshold you wanted but it's it's
as close as I can get right now yeah
yeah there's a question in the back yes
Michael I'm going to intervene oh okay I
I'm sure there are many more questions
but fortunately we're about to have a
reception and Gary will uh join us next
door in the common room so each of you
can ask some questions but let me first
thank you for coming to our company of
Scholars lectures this year thank Gary
for a splendid thought-provoking uh
presentation invite you all to the
reception and then uh express my hope
that my successor next year will
continue the company of Scholars
lectures because they've been so much
fun thank you all thank you thank you
all thank you
thank you
fun